Steve Neil author of Harry and Ike the
partnership that remade the post-war
world where did you get the idea for
this book well I have done several
surveys over the last twenty years of
leading historians ranking the president
sort of on the Arthur Schlessinger
senior model and in each of these
surveys we've done three or since 1981
Truman and Eisenhower ranked as the best
presidents of the last half-century I
also noticed in that when I was getting
rid of some of my books the Hopkins
edition of Dwight the Eisenhower's
papers I noticed a lot of letters to
clean Harry Truman and the what most
people think of Truman Eisenhower is
their feud and they don't realize how
closely they work together they probably
work together I found from reading their
their letters more closely than any two
presidents of the 20th century between
1950 45 in 1952 and and so I found that
there were all these wonderful letters
and I thought that there was a book
there I first suggested my friend
professor Robert Farrell that he might
be interested since Bob had edited Ike's
diaries and a done a fine Truman
biography and he said why don't you do
it and so he talked me into it what's
the origin of this picture on the cover
that picture was taken about fifty years
ago when Ike was going to NATO a supreme
Allied commander President Truman and
just named him and I believe that
picture was taken out at Andrews Air
Force Base of President Truman greeting
him when he came back in January of 1951
where did they first meet they first met
here in Washington DC in June of 1945
just shortly after the Allied victory in
Europe President Truman declared
virtually a federal holiday here and I
spoke before a joint session of Congress
paid tribute to President Truman there
Truman decorated on the lawn of the
White House he whispered to him that he
would rather Trump Heath Truman would
rather have the medal than the
presidency and then he had a dinner for
him that night up at the White House
President Truman wrote his wife Bess
that night that
he said that Ike seems like a heck of a
fellow he said they're talking about him
for president I'd give him the job now
if I could Truman was just getting into
the job and they both so they they both
were this was new for Ike too because he
had been so close to Franklin D
Roosevelt and he hadn't quite known what
to expect of this new president that he
had known much about what was the
difference in their age Ike was born in
1890 and President Truman was born in
1884 Saturn was six years older than him
and they really can't come from not only
the same generation but the thing I
found fascinating is that for fifteen
years from 1945 until January of 61 our
country was run by people who grew up in
small towns 150 miles apart from each
other in the heart of America where did
Dwight Eisenhower come from specifically
well Ike was born in Texas but he only
lived there a brief time because his
family he grew up in Abilene Kansas
which was an old cattle town and it is
and it is so fascinating that when you
cross the river to go into Kansas even
though Missouri and Kansas are both
thought of as Midwestern when you're in
Abilene you really feel like you're in
the West it is not that much of a drive
to Colorado you see all the the the
Western historic sights you're near Fort
Riley which has the cavalry museum and
so even though geographically there are
only hundred 50 miles apart it is Ike in
some ways is as much Westerner as as mid
Westerner did you spend any time out
there at the library oh I spent many
half-dozen trips to each to independence
into Abilene and spent a lot of time I
think that that one of the great values
of the Presidential Library System is to
spend time in the cultures in the in the
communities where presidents grew up you
don't get the same feeling I don't think
in in in the reading room or the Library
of Congress that you do out in in
Abilene or Independence or West Branch
or Hyde Park or wherever one might be
yeah
and it was so useful to spend time the
Eisenhower's for example really were
from the the poor side of the tracks you
know there are great homes in and there
are people with great fortunes in his
hometown of Abilene the Truman's also
work came from a very modest background
I mean he grew up on both Harry and Ike
I had grew up sort of on the edge of
poverty I mean that their fathers
Truman's father went broke at one time
so did Eisenhower's they were they but
same time they had they both had
self-confidence and we're not did not
have like say someone like Richard Nixon
or maybe Lyndon Johnson have feel
insecure about where they came from they
they were very comfortable with where
they came from and I can the famous
speech of course after World War two
told in London speaking for the problems
I come from from the very heart of
America what were his parents like Ike's
parents were hard-working people his
father was the foreman in the local
Creamery his mother Ida was very
well-read disciplined and she I think it
was partly from her that he got his
drivin ambition she was she believed in
education hard work and so his parents
had a great influence his father was a
very humane decent guy but the mother
had more of the drive I would say that
that was also the case in on President
Truman's side his mother had more spark
and his father like Ikes
I sort of struggled how did Dwight
Eisenhower get to the military academy
well this is really fascinating I could
been a terrific athlete in high school
as it's his older brother he had
initially wanted to go and probably go
to a Big Ten school or something as his
brother Arthur went to Michigan but one
of his close friends went was going to
the Naval Academy and that's where Ike
wanted to go to and he applied to go to
Annapolis but the opening was for West
Point and so he winds up going to West
Point in oddly enough
President Truman had won it was
President Truman's ambition before
or Eisenhower to go to West Point but
because of his poor eyesight he was
ineligible course he serves in the
reserves the National Guard and the
military plays a very important part in
shaping President Truman
so he went he's at West Point and what
years and how close to the World War One
together Mike is in West Point in the
era of 1910 1911 in there in a number of
there are a number of people who I come
out of there of great prominence such as
general Bradley for example Ike is a
football star there and is his picture
is in the New York Times as one of the
brightest running backs in the East he
plays against Jim Thorpe in one one game
but his his his sports career is cut
short by injury now Ike was not an
academic star at West Point unlike
someone like General MacArthur for
example who graduated with the highest
grade average in the history of the
Academy Ike was a so-so student but he
had he was very well-liked he got a lot
of demerits he once said later in life
he thought anyone who didn't go through
West Point with the number Damaris
wasn't worth their salt he was a tough
guy a very strong person which is often
I think the public doesn't understand
about him but he he it is one of his
great regrets that he after getting out
at West Point he goes among other places
to Fort Sam Houston where he meets and
marries Mamie Dowd who was from a
wealthy family from Denver and he as
World War one when the u.s. enters World
War one Ike is anxious to serve overseas
and he is frustrated because he has
given a job training soldiers here
including he runs a camp for training
people in tanks in tank warfare which is
a relly new technology it was a and
among the challenge he had was they
didn't even have tanks for him to teach
this but he was very good very efficient
he had orders at one time to go over but
but but he was asked to stay in the
States which was a very bitter pill for
him finally when he does get a chance it
looks like he's going overseas the
armistice is signed and
so he feels that the world has passed it
by you see other people like General
MacArthur who's a little bit older than
him making names for themselves for but
but Ike Eisenhower felt that that that
prominence had passed him him him by and
so the in the time after he is
frustrated for a long time in the
service and in at one time thinks about
switching to become a newspaper
correspond but that's later on Harry
Truman's original birthplace again was
where Truman was born in leave was Lamar
he is but he grows up in Independence
and he he grows up on the family farm
and in he but as a while still in his in
in in grammar school he moves into the
town of Independence but he he is very
rooted on the farm because he has
grandparents who have a farm and his in
the farm stays in the Truman family for
many years but he he loves the one thing
he loves about independence is Truman is
a little guy he's not athletic he loves
to read he later said later in life that
he read every book in the local library
in Independence I don't know if he did
that or not that seems like quite a bit
but he was very well read and one thing
I found fascinating is that Truman and I
read a number of the same things they
both like military histories they both
admired hannibal was someone there was a
biographies of hannibal that came out
around that time and they both were
interested in the Civil War
and so but Truman is I think the chance
to go into independence and to to go to
the larger school really opened up
horizons for him seven years difference
yes Harry Truman seven years older six
six years yes what how much schooling
did he have well Harry Truman is the
last president of the United States that
did not have a college education
now there is no doubt that Truman could
have died if he could have gone to
school would have been a very good
student he's a very smart learning man
but his family had fine
setbacks and his his father expected him
to work in help support his family and
Truman did that he was a very loyal guy
there was one point that I found very
moving he is in Kansas City not long out
of high school he's working a number of
jobs but he has a job in a bank in
Kansas City he's doing pretty well but
the father asked him to come back and
work on the family farm Truman does this
in a minute never questions it and he is
thinks he's going to be could be stuck
on the farm for you know a long time but
he also cared for his mother and father
honored his family and and did that and
yet during the same time he is he is
interested in courting a best Wallace
she it's a long courtship and one that
they don't get married actually until
after he returns from World War one so
go back to write World War one started
what year well the u.s. intervened in
World War one in 1917
it's what President Wilson's re-elected
to us with the slogan he kept us out of
war we go in in 1917 and it is in Harry
Truman is in the Missouri National Guard
and he is elected captain ultimately of
his battery and serves in Europe sees
combat and his emergence really as a
leader he has has that he has a great
respect he and one case one famous
incident David McCullough wrote about it
in his book also there's a confrontation
with with a superior officer when when a
member of of Truman's battery is wounded
Truman has the soldier on a horse in
that and Truman's told that you know get
him off he can't do the only officers
but but but Truman stood his ground he
was someone they loved him he felt this
bond with his men for the rest of his
life in the Truman library you see this
wonderful correspondence between him and
the people he served with also his
letters to best during this period are
very moving he didn't know why he had
never seen a shot fired in anger he did
there I think that one of the reasons
why he was effective as
a as a military leader as president was
it he had had this experience of serving
in war which book is this for you this
is number seven
what were their kinds of subjects did
you write about or say I am originally
from Oregon and so I did three books on
Oregon related topics one I did it by a
the autobiography of the lasering
governor Tom McCall a great character
called maverick that came out about
twenty four years ago I did a biography
of Charlie McNary who was a Republican
leader in the Senate from the during the
rows of Franklin Roosevelt yours and and
I did a book on I went to McNary High
School Salem Oregon one reason why I
have had interest in him but I did my
favorite book before this oh and I did a
collection of Richard Newberg of
Oregon's writings identical they never
go back to Pocatello which was still a
saying here in Washington that was a and
then I he was the father's wife became
senator moree Neuberger became a senator
and she just died this year she was
great lady she was the third woman
elected to the US Senate and a wonderful
person she wrote the foreword to that
book and I did a book on the man who
chose Charlie McNary's his running mate
Wendell Willkie before this book I would
say that that was my favorite book of
Wilkie is just a remarkable story one of
the great conventions in 1940 one of my
oldest friends is Spencer Tracy's
biographer Larry Swindell Larry told me
that when I was asking him if he thought
Wilkie had possibilities as a book or a
film he said well Spencer Tracy already
played him in the movies that's in the
Tracy Hepburn movie State of the Union
which the character grant Matthews is
based on one to walkie why do you write
books I enjoyed I enjoy I enjoy reading
the the writing kind of books I that I'd
like to read I enjoy political
biographies in American history and so
much so the thing that strikes me when
we go to our prison to libraries or the
Library of Congress is there so much
rich primary source material that hasn't
been tapped and I have I usually have
several ideas for every book I do I've
got I've had some false starts
this one took about four years to do
they do take time because I do three
columns a week for the Chicago sun-times
covering politics so that's a full-time
job and so it I takes me time to do
these and I think you have to have a
real passion for this subject I knew the
late theater white and admired his work
he was one of the reasons I thought that
writing political history and making it
fresh and come alive is something that
that I thought was possible and Teddy
White's a real hero of mine and I hope
that some of my books with the standard
that he would have approved of how long
have you live in Chicago
I've lived in Chicago papers for 22
years I've been out there since I was
four since 1983 I was here in Washington
for a time as the covering national
politics and the White House for the
Chicago Tribune which is I worked for
for eight years I've been with the
Chicago sun-times for about 15 go back
to we have Harry Truman and Dwight
Eisenhower up to and past the World War
one again six-year difference in their
age how old would Harry Truman have been
right after World War 1 1917 well see
and he would have been in his 16 in his
30s he was born 1884 233 married yeah he
marries best on his return and he is he
goes into business and opens the
haberdashery with his friend Eddie
Jacobson they for a brief time they're
successful but then when the economic
downturn hits there's a recession he
goes broke and he he's determined to pay
off his creditors and he does it takes
him a long time it's not until he's a
number of years into the Senate but but
what when when he when his business
fails Truman has such a network of
friends from his World War one service
that one of the people that he got to
know in the service was a member of the
Pendergast family and the Pendergast ran
the Kansas City Democratic machine
Truman gets slated for the job is called
judge of Jackson County it actually is
more like a county commissioner and he
gets elected and it is a very productive
member of the Jackson County Court
or when most of America would be to be
the County Board of Commissioners but in
one of the Republican landslides that
twenties he gets defeated and some
people would have dropped out of
politics
Truman sort of enjoyed it and he comes
back and is elected as chief judge of
Jackson County which is like being the
head of the of county government in one
of the great metropolitan areas in this
country he makes a terrific record he
builds a number of roads he builds new
courthouses he is admired for his
honesty and for he works though he is
one among them are more partisan
presidents one things about Truman I
think it's not understood is how well he
worked with Republican people across the
aisle and how well he worked with
business establishment as well as as
well as organized labor and so he he
makes a terrific record there get a
little mention in your book about Dwight
Eisenhower's brother and Harry Truman
this is fascinating to me that the
Arthur Eisenhower one of Ike's older
brothers also worked for a bank in
Kansas City the same time Harry Truman
did they live in the same boardinghouse
and Truman says later he taught I told
showed up Arthur Eisenhower how to turn
on a gas jet that and during World War
two when Ike is being urged to think
about running for elective office then
Senator Harry Truman gives Arthur
Eisenhower some advice now his brother
can avoid this if he wants to so he
Truman always had great affection for
Arthur Eisenhower so he did one of our
earlier books here suggested that they
were roommates together so they were
just rooming house mates no they were
not roommates they they were in the same
boarding house and they would share
meals they would share common meals he
knew him but no they were not roommates
what about the brothers and sisters have
both harry truman and white Eisner well
President Truman had a sister who lived
for quite a while he also had had a
brother I had know less about the
Truman's that I do about the
Eisenhower's his one book I didn't
mention to you Brian was I did a book on
the Eisenhower family that Doubleday
published in 1978 and they are all all
brothers and they come from this small
town yet they all have lives of real
distinction I mean
becomes the president becomes a college
present as a distinguished career in
government beginning in the 1920s with
the Department of Agriculture and
serving in administration's from
Coolidge through FDR when he becomes
president of successively Kansas State
Penn State and finally Johns Hopkins but
a very distinguished educator and in
public servant brother Roy was a
pharmacist he died young Arthur
Eisenhower was quite an accomplished
lawyer after getting on the University
of Michigan he goes to Tacoma Washington
practices law there he's the most
conservative member of the family Milton
was probably the most liberal and then
there was paralyzed in Hauer who is a
was involved in publishing
he was very engaging but not not quite
as as much of a hard charger as some of
the other brothers he is elected to the
Illinois legislature when there is an
at-large election for the legislature in
the mid-1960s and a very likable guy he
died young also in so so the but the
Eisenhower brothers were very close you
see pictures of them fishing together
they they have a very close-knit family
and yet you know again just to this
great American story Truman was very
close and connected his family too you
see these wonderful letters to his
sister to his mother and people just
don't write those kind of letters
anymore we have email and long-distance
phones and yeah and yet we were so
fortunate to have these Rickett written
records of both the Truman's in the
Eisenhower's because I think it tells
you a lot about what made them tick you
say that you talked to both Dwight
Eisenhower son John who was a general
also and Clifton Truman Daniel's yes
Clifton is President Truman's oldest
grandson he was very helpful he has done
a book himself about growing up with his
grandfather that is excellent and so I
gained a number of insights from him how
old a man is Clifton was born in 1957
and what you say is associated with
Harry Truman collar he is the he is the
spokesman for director of public affairs
for harry s truman college and the city
chicago is part of his it's a community
college and he came out as a
commencement speaker a few years ago and
i clifton had been in involved in
journalism in north carolina and was
invited to join there
Elian has done a terrific job he is he
is just he's also a very gifted writer
his late father Clifton Daniel was a
great knows one of New York Times and
his mother Margaret is a very successful
and accomplished writer who doesn't
excellent books on both of her parents
what about John Eisenhower the son of
well John Eisenhower is an old friend he
was not too enthused about me doing this
book he was very helpful my earlier book
on his family one of the reasons is I
think that he likes to be thought of as
something other than an expert on the
Eisenhower years since he's quite a
distinguished writer in his own right I
think he was also concerned that this
would make them the conflict they both
might look bad but in fact their
collaboration I think is is a story
that's that they both look pretty good
now the conflict was unfortunate John's
take on what happened was that his
father should probably been more
attentive to Truman's ego at times and
that in that Truman should have been
less personal in some of his attacks on
his father during the 1952 campaign but
Jonathas stage of his life really
doesn't want to be thought of as a
commentator on the Eisenhower years and
so you didn't see him when that when the
History Channel riesen did did a special
on Nixon eisenhower John was not did not
participate in that and he still
continues to turn out good works of
military history what's the difference
between the Eisenhower library and a
baleen and the Truman library and
independence this is sort of fasting
Brian I find that each library sir takes
on the personality of a president and in
the Abilene it's a little more formal as
you might expect from something that
from a guy who served in the military
and and is a little more aloof than
truman so it's they're very helpful very
nice but it is more you get the feeling
more like it could be at a War College
or something
whereas independence is very just a much
more relaxed low-key
informal like President Truman I
personally became pretty close to a
number of the people at the Truman
library the book is dedicated to
Elizabeth safley this wonderful lady who
is the reference librarian there in who
is so helpful to all of us makes it so
pleasant for all of us who do research
there she was working at the library she
grew up in Independence and she was a
just out of school when President Truman
was still there and still presence at
the library so she is among a few
remaining people there who has a tie to
President Truman but their whole archive
there's another archivist named Dennis
Belcher who is mentioned in all the
books untrim he's legendary in the
archival system and when you come to the
Truman library they will have a truck of
files waiting for you so that you could
maximize the use of your time and I have
never all the libraries are great I've
worked at about six of the presidential
libraries
none of them are betting better Harry
Truman that's that libraries has the
standard you tell us that you've got a
grant from the harry s truman library
institute how does that work in it did
that does it
prejudice you really no I have great it
helped pay for a couple trips down there
but I the Eisenhower library has been
very generous over the years I gave a
speech was the main speaker at the 25th
anniversary of the Eisenhower library in
1987 and and they have been no I have
great I also did the first cover story
at Ike that appeared in American
heritage in thing why we were right to
like Ike appeared in 1985 so I have I
think both of these are our great
American figures the but they have
differences in the in differences in
temperament styles and obviously the
there there are backgrounds what year
did Dwight Eisenhower become a general
and what year did Harry Truman become
and Senator well Harry Truman's elected
to the Senate in 1934 and so he and he's
he's 50 and I guess his first star right
before the u.s. goes into World War two
he gets his first start Ike is so
frustrated in thinking during the 1920s
and 30s that because there were so few
promotions the army was really dumb size
after World War one that he almost
became the military correspondent for a
national newspaper chain and he is
frustrated working under General Douglas
MacArthur both his army chief of staff
later the Philippines
and so but when it becomes apparent that
the u.s. is going to enter World War two
he is very anxious to serve this time
because he missed out in World War one
and he returns home and he becomes a
star in what was known as the Luiz
Louisiana maneuver is the largest
peacetime maneuvers in history Ike is a
is a terrific strategist and tactician
his star really Rises he also has caught
the attention of General George C
Marshall the army chief of staff and it
is general Marshall who and President
Roosevelt who promote Ike and recognize
his potential and I during all this time
and really keeps a diary and and and
which is wonderful for giving his
insights into his feelings not only
about the war but different individuals
and so it is possible really sort of the
chart Ike's Ike's evolution as a thinker
and also it's easy to see why some of
his disdain toward different figures
such as General MacArthur who he
suffered under I think he had the
admiration for him in some ways but you
really learn a lot from reading his
diary I don't think he anticipated it
would that the general public would be
reading it jumping ahead go back to
picture we showed earlier this is the
Rose Garden in June of 1945 their first
meeting they didn't ever know each other
until that time no they had a Eisenhower
had heard you know vaguely about the
senator from Missouri who had been
elected I found in some Arthur
Eisenhower's correspondence with I
there's a reference that he had this
conversation with senator Truman giving
him advice about how to avoid going to
politics if he didn't want to but they
they didn't Truman had a great
admiration for Eisenhower as a soldier
but had in fact in his diary in Truman's
diary he puts Ike on his pedestal with
general Marshall and end robert e lee
and and and then he disdains the brass
hat typed the MacArthur's
patents in George Armstrong Custer
where's this picture from right here
that picture below of which General
Patton in the center was taken in
occupied Berlin and the the flag is
flying up over the US occupied zone and
it was on that day that President Truman
stunned General Eisenhower general
Bradley is also in the car when he looks
at him he says general there's nothing
that I wouldn't do for you and that
specifically includes the presidency in
1948 well Ike is stunned you have the
president the United States in effect
offering to support him for the
presidency I laughs laughs and says mr.
president I don't know who your opponent
will be in 1948 it will not be I but
Truman brings Ike home later ought to
succeed
I should mention Brian with General
Patton in there General Patton gave Ike
headaches as military governor because
he above area right after the work as he
he wouldn't follow administration policy
in and challenge publicly questioned
that I can't to relieve him which is
very painful and of course Patton has
killed certainly after that not long
after that picture is taken but Ike
returns late that year is named by
President Truman as general Marshalls
successor as army chief of staff and
then serves Truman it this is sort of a
job that I kinds a distasteful because
after leading history's greatest
invasion he presides over the
dismantling of the of the army and it's
very frustrating is under pressure some
families want them to come home sooner
Ike doesn't want to leave the nation
vulnerable with the because there's
question of Soviet expansionism at that
time and Truman at one point persists
with his idea of approaching Eisenhower
about running as the Democratic nominee
for president 1948 Creelman despite the
image we see of him holding up the
Chicago Tribune and looking at like with
the swagger and the confidence was a
very modest man in many ways he when he
first became president he he didn't know
that if he was up the job he said there
there must been a thousand people more
qualified than me he also knew
the Democrats particularly after the
1946 election when they lost both houses
of Congress could have a hard time in
1948 he saw Eisenhower as one person who
could preserve the New Deal coalition at
one point through the Secretary of the
army he sends word that he would be
willing to run as vice president if I
would head the Democratic ticket Ike is
consistent though in saying that he does
not have an interest although in a
conversation with walter Lippmann he
once wonders if there's a possibility
that both parties might draft him in
1948 but he steps down as chief of staff
in 1948 writes a letter to a New
Hampshire publisher saying he didn't
believe that the people in the military
should go into politics and President
Truman is so grateful that he gives
iechyd tax break on his book crusade in
Europe which is a terrific book one of
the great memoirs written I think it
ranks was general Grant's memoirs one of
the great books written by an American
soldier but this makes icould wealthy
man is before you leave that to tell
tell us how that happened
well max break well the Ike had great
lawyers one of them was Joe Davies who
was the famous ambassador Moscow and
very well-connected poker playing friend
of President Truman's but President
Truman called the IRS commissioner and
talked to the Secretary of the Treasury
and said I want you to do this for Ike I
found a document confirming that in the
terminal library and so I gets this huge
advance which would be comparable to the
up in the up of the millions now it was
in the hundreds of thousands then but
and that was a time when you've had an
85 percent tax bracket but instead of
doing this
Truman rule that Ike wasn't a
professional writer this was property
that he was selling so he could declare
a capital gain on it so I becomes a
fairly wealthy man by the standards of
the time and Harry Truman made that
possible
now Truman sort of resented that years
later when he is struggling he has to
sell off part of the family farm to make
ends meet there because there is no
presidential pension at the time when he
leaves office and he almost loses money
on him his memoirs although he's paid
he's paid a six-figure advance
serializing Life magazine he does not
make money out cuz he didn't get the
special break that I did now after
Truman gave Ike that tax break Congress
passed something known as the Eisenhower
tax law which closed that loophole and
but Truman thought I earned it for his
service to the country and won
you know and so he never flinched at
doing that for eisenhower we can come
back and talk about some of the other
things they got along during the years
of about but jump to where where was the
first falling out well they they were
fifty years ago they were still close
when I goes to Europe a supreme Allied
commander of NATO but in in Truman tries
to hit is pretty sure he doesn't want to
run for reelection in 1952 although he
could he was grandfathered under the
two-term constitutional amendment but he
offers to back Ike again as a Democrat
Ike in November of 1951 tells him that
he if he runs it would be as a
Republican and so Truman can accept this
he has great respect for Eisenhower and
so he when I comes home from NATO in
June of 52 he decorates Ike has him
upstairs and and they have a drink in
the White House study and he says gives
Ike some advice i complaining about
being attacked and the that picture was
taken on the day when i came back and
you can see that there are HST is in an
expansive mood Ike is complaining about
a whispering campaign by the right-wing
against him Truman says if that's all
all there is it's a nothing to worry
about
but in Ike is nominated in 52 at the
Republican mr. Truman thought he would
lose to Bob Taft for the nomination
because it was I just barely won the
nomination over Bob Taft what kind of a
Republican was generalizing
General Eisenhower would be a moderate
Republican would be he certainly was in
in he was an internationalist but in in
domestic affairs in some ways he was too
Bob Taft right and that's something that
Eisenhower would not have run for
president 1952 if he made an offer to
Bob Taft that he met with him at the
Pentagon and if tax Senator Taft leader
the Senate Republicans had endorsed the
Truman foreign policy in Europe the
right of the u.s. to participate in NATO
Ike wouldn't have run to have declined
to do that
and so that was a factor in Ike's
decision to run Ike also supported
Truman in that his decision to fire
General Douglas MacArthur he thought for
his very public insubordination that
famous picture wonderful picture when
Ike's reaction taken by Stars and
Stripes with that what after because I
didn't think that Truman would actually
do it but he's fully supported his
decision why he firing Truman fired
MacArthur for publicly defying
administration policy in Korea and for
writing a letter to among other things
to the House Republican leader Joe
Martin disagreeing with administration
policy the supreme Allied commander
MacArthur was supposed to be carrying
out so MacArthur made it very different
Ike had for years been appalled by
MacArthur insubordination including the
routing of the bonus marchers in 1932
when MacArthur ignored a directive from
the from the White House went across the
bridge and routed the bonus marchers and
needlessly humiliated them I thought
this was cruel and inhumane and he
believed in civilian control of the
military something was General MacArthur
didn't always share stop for a moment
and talk about Korea Korea started win
the war the war starts the US
intervention is right after that the
North Korean invasion of June of 1950
whereas General Eisenhower then Ike is
Ike was in New York what when he got the
news but he rushes to Washington after
because he knows that his he will and he
consults the Joint Chiefs when was the
president of Columbia knew he was
president Columbia University from 1948
until his his resignation in 1952 on
being elected president of the United
States he was on leave for much of that
time though because half that time he
was working for President Truman as his
chief military adviser after the 1948
election psych was very bored at
Columbia after what he'd been through
and then of course in 1951 he comes in
52 early 52 as supreme Allied commander
of NATO and so why he really believed
strongly in the Truman foreign policy he
disagrees with much of the Truman
domestic policy and but Bryan the
question you asked earlier about their
break
in August of Truman understood the
Republican platform which denounced his
administration even though I could been
a participant in the foreign policy I
couldn't write the platform the Bob Taft
wing of the party wrote the platform the
break starts in August of 1952 Ike is
staying at the Brown Palace Hotel in
Denver which was his headquarters and
Truman has a briefing at the White House
with Governor Adlai Stevenson of
Illinois Eisenhower had such respect for
Stevenson that John Eisenhower told me
once that I told him that had he known
governor Stevenson would have been the
Democratic nominee he never would have
gone into politics because he had great
respect for Stevenson
but when Stevenson attended a briefing
at the White House with the Truman
cabinet in foreign policy team Ike
criticizes Stevenson as as being a
captive of the Truman foreign policy and
the Truman team and said this would be
business as usual well President Truman
invites Eisenhower to this same briefing
with the CIA director Walter Bedell
Smith Ike's World War two deputy and
with the Dean Acheson and in the cabinet
I respectfully declines it and puts out
a telegram by saying that he has
declined this saying that in his new
role he did not feel it was appropriate
for him to do so
Truman wrote him a letter Bryan if I
could show it to you that he said he
says that he is sorry if he is causing
any embarrassment that he thinks that he
is loud some crackpots that come between
them because he has threatened the
bipartisan foreign policy of which
Eisenhower had been a big part and he
says finally that he's sorry if he cause
him any embarrassment from one who
always meant to be your friend and
always tried to be Ike writes back a
handwritten note very respectful saying
mr. president you've caused me no
embarrassment but that in my eye I feel
that there's since there was no
emergency it was not urgent for me to be
there in that it might be misunderstood
if he went in attended this briefing and
so he but Eisenhower in fact is insulted
that then tells Walter Bedell Smith that
he got a letter from a high personage
with wounded dignity about AI
now we're not coming to the meeting now
President Truman felt that Ike had
showed disrespect not just for Harry
Truman but the office of presidency of
the of the United States and Truman ah
always heard differentiated those so he
would never I could always come before
when Truman had called but course
Eisenhower had always been his his
subordinate in the past so later that
fall when Ike Ike is running with some
people that he doesn't really care to be
in the same room with such as William
Jenner of Indiana who was a real hater
and in sort of a kook in a read Bader
but most of all Joseph R McCarthy of
Wisconsin there is a tough decision
Thomas C Dewey who is one of Ike's major
advisors advises Ike not to go to
Wisconsin because the he would be on the
same stage with McCarthy there was sharp
dissension in the campaign
Eisenhower ultimately decides to go to
Wisconsin because Truman had carried
Wisconsin there was some question that
that this would be a close election
Eisenhower also is booked to be on the
same stage and to ride the train with
with Joe McCarthy now Eisenhower told
his speechwriter Emmett John Hughes
let's put a paragraph in where I comment
about George Marshall my esteem for
George Marshall that would be am a way
of helping of salvaging some dignity out
of sharing the stage with McCarthy Ike
is pressured not to do this by the
moderate Governor of Wisconsin Walter
Koehler and Sherman Adams Eisenhower's
campaign manager thinks that I should
listen to governor Koehler he takes out
this reference dis defense of general
Marshall the text leaks and it's
published in the New York Times that
that Eisenhower has an effect
surrendered to McCarthy and shared the
same stage with him and Truman now has
an issue to go after and Ripon dies
marrow doesn't he goes all across the
country saying that this showed moral
cowardice and you can't trust someone
who doesn't stand by their friends and I
have great respect for General
Eisenhower but he's bowed to expediency
and Truman became increasingly vitriolic
in his attacks there was one unfortunate
attack when there was a little-known
senator from West Virginia named
revver comb who was the Republican
sponsor of the McCarran act which was
discriminatory a revision of the u.s.
immigration law that discriminated
against Catholics and Jews revver comb
was such a caveman that Thomas II do in
1948 wouldn't appear with him but
General Eisenhower 952 did and he
President Truman issues a statement
basically saying that the he is appalled
that the person who helped liberate
Europe from those who believe in the
master race is now appearing with them
an effect suggesting that that Ike was
aligning himself with fascism and I
think Truman went over the top on that
thing and he later issued a
clarification the next day Ike was livid
at that but another thing that Truman
knew that Eisenhower was gonna win this
election he was the most popular person
in the country Bryan is a telegram here
that if I could find it that he sent
that that that President Truman sent
general eisenhower after
can you see a telegram when it's on the
bottom I saw it in the stacker or maybe
still is here I control place where he
is
he says general President Truman says
congratulations on your overwhelming
victory and that the presidential
aircraft is available if you still want
to go now what he meant but Mike right
before the election pledges if elected
he will go to Korea and this turned a
close election into a route because
nobody there was no American soldier
with more prestige in Dwight Eisenhower
and he an effect pledged to end the war
in Korea well Truman attack this is a
campaign demagoguery at its worst and
noted that I could been part of the
decision to withdraw a career from the
US defense perimeter as chief of staff
but Ike was genuine in his commitment to
go there and try and do something to end
the war but the Truman's by putting in
the freight if you still want to go Ike
was again was incensed didn't know if he
could even write down Pennsylvania
Avenue with the Truman he was so angry
Truman though once the election was over
thought that buy guns could be buy guns
and he was determined he had been
uninformed about many issues when he
became president he put together the
first formal transition office worked
very hard to have a smooth princess you
can see in that picture with Ike straw
how it was a not a warm meeting and that
was the only meeting they had in between
the the June of 52 in that famous ride
in January of 1953 when they rode to the
Capitol together
President Truman was offended when he
and mrs. Truman invited general mrs.
Eisenhower to the White House for her
coffee and sandwiches before going up
for the inaugural ceremonies they
declined
President Truman thought that again this
was insulting mrs. Truman in fact
Eisenhower was Ike having been in the
military all this year did not really
understand partisanship and Truman had
many friends with people who had savaged
him far worse than he had gone after
Eisenhower but this was a real rift and
they would not Truman as a goodwill
gesture brought John Eisenhower home
from Korea during the John had known who
was responsible for doing this so during
the via ride to the capital of General
Eisenhower says to President Truman who
do you know who brought my son back from
Korea and you can still tell him that
contrary old man from Missouri did and
then I Claytor did write Truman a note
thanking him for this Truman as someone
who had just one child as the
Eisenhower's did they had a John was the
their only son the other son earlier who
died thought John should be there I
think the Eisenhower's greatly
appreciated this kind gesture on
Truman's part but but it would be a
number of years before there was a warm
conversation between Truman and night
when was the first time they had a warm
conversation they nodded at each other
at justice Fred Vincent's funeral and
but they they did not really have a
President Eisenhower invited President
Truman to the White House three times
during his second term for the 10th
anniversary of NATO when NATO foreign
ministers were meeting in Washington for
the dedication of the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier in
the Korean War and for a stag dinner
Winston Churchill on each time Truman
found excuses so they didn't actually
have a conversation until General
Eisenhower broke the ice late in 1961
when he calls on President Truman at the
Truman library they have a friendly
conversation Truman gives him a personal
tour of the library and then a few weeks
later they go to the funeral the other
pictures you show to their friend Sam
Rayburn the great House Speaker in Texas
but what really brings them back
together was that terrible weekend in
1963 when John F Kennedy has been shot
President Truman his daughter Margaret
are staying at Blair House former
President Eisenhower and mrs. Eisenhower
drive down from Gettysburg they go to
the service JFK's service with the
Truman's they come go to the gravesite
with the Truman's and I there been so
few people have been present of the
United States I do think they felt the
coming of a bond and remembered some of
the great things that they had done
together and they after coming back from
the gravesite at Arlington
they have lunch a light lunch at Blair
House and it's a very warm friendly
conversation they really become sort of
comrades again 63 how old were each of
them how much time do they have to live
well prison Eisenhower would die in 1969
he had six years yes and President
Truman lives for another President
Truman lives until late 1972 and dies
just a few weeks before Lyndon Johnson
so that when they're in the Blair House
together what kind of shape are they in
Fizz
is still pretty vital and is is in good
shape Truman is is still in fairly good
shape too although he the the
deterioration starts fairly quickly
after then he has has some injuries not
long after that and stops going to the
library every day as as he had been
doing but at that time they are still
they both speak to the nation
in Truman in an informal sidewalk
setting in Eisenhower also on a sidewalk
in New York when he learns the news of
JFK's death and I think that that
weekend the reconciliation between these
two great figures was a very bright
thing a good thing for the country at
this sad time did they ever have a
natural relationship after that they
they had a warmer relationship but it
was still formal it was never as it was
during the great years between 1945 and
50 to one of Ike's speech writers built
a Ewald did a book it helped Ike with
his memoirs and recalls that when Ike is
putting in a list of the towering
figures of the West that he worked with
he at first omits President Truman but
then he puts him in fairly close to the
top and when I casques President Truman
to be the co-chair of a 50th wedding
anniversary for him and Mamie for as a
fundraiser for a college that his name
for Eisenhower Truman gladly does this
he also helps Ike with the fundraising
drive for world war ii memorial in
britain and Ike when he paced and made
me take the train because Mamie didn't
like to fly to Palm Springs every winter
would would send a telegram to or try
and call President Truman from the Train
and so but they their last meeting is in
1966 in Kansas City and fittingly is at
a luncheon for the United Nations which
they both believed in very strongly and
they I think that their cooperation in
shaping NATO I don't know that two other
leaders could have done it because only
Eisenhower had the prestige to get NATO
off and running in 1951 and they both
believed strongly in the UN what do you
personally think was the real problem
between the two of them yeah I think
that it was a difference in backgrounds
I think that that that Ike is a
five-star general
I had not been used to the criticism
that that comes in in politics and so I
think that he did not understand that
that when Truman went after him with
with the these vitriolic attacks that
that that this happens it in politics in
the case of President
I think he probably did go too far in in
some of those same time I think Truman
was very hurt when he tried to call on
General Eisenhower when President
Eisenhower his first business president
went to Kansas City Truman called up to
Eisenhower suite and was an effect blown
off by a staffer and I don't believe
that I ever got the message that day I
did not believe that i quiz still angry
but I will never believe that he would
have slighted someone who occupied the
office that he held I think he felt
badly about it when he learned about it
and what a general Schultz who was one
of my aides said President Truman made a
mistake making it call himself rather
than having a staffer do it so that yet
but it was an unfortunate incident that
that made I think that was one of the
reasons why Truman he again felt he was
shown disrespect and discourtesy why he
did not respond when I invited him to
the White House in this later occasions
did you find any evidence of a
relationship between Bess Truman and
Mamie Eisenhower you know they had a
friendly relationship they took a
Spanish class together at one time when
when best was either the wife of the
senator or a vice president and mrs.
Eisenhower was living in Washington and
her and Ike was in World War two and
they had they had genuine affection I
think for each other and when when
Margaret Truman went to Europe when Ike
was supreme Allied commander of NATO the
Eisenhower's had had dinner with
Margaret and in and at the same time
President Truman thought very highly of
John Eisenhower in John Eisenhower told
me once that he had visited with
President Truman not long before
Truman's death at the Truman library
they had a very warm visit any
relationship between John Eisenhower and
Clifton Truman Daniel or Margaret Daniel
his daughter I don't think so John was
very appalled when Merle Miller's book
plain speaking came out which a number
of statements are attributed to Merrill
Miller about President Eisenhower which
I learned from doing this book I think
Merle Miller invented made-up I laid him
out I've listened to Merle Miller tapes
I
think that book is a is a book of
untruths
yes Lange speak yes and President Truman
threatened to sue Morel Miller during
his lifetime when Morel Miller asked
about publishing some notes from some
interviews he did as a background
reporter for David Susskind and so many
of the remarks and then the the incident
that Merle Miller alleges that President
Truman destroyed correspondence that Ike
wanted to divorce
Mamie to Mary Kay Summersby that
correspondence never existed I think
again that I think someone told Miller
about this but yet there's no evidence
that that ever happened and I think that
contributed to some of the bad blood
that some people of the Eisenhower and
Truman camps I kind of remember wasn't
plain speaking a big seller huge seller
but it came out right after President
Truman's death and President Truman I
never uttered many of the statements
there in that book I've listened to the
tapes and it is most unfortunate
more in Mena truman could be outspoken
in his criticism of many individuals and
uh uh but many of the juiciest quotes
are not on those tapes
well the tapes that the interviews
between Merrill Muller and Harry Truman
yes and how did you get access to him
there are there are settlers tapes at
the Truman library now the Johnson
library has most of them because the
people the Truman library do not have
any respect for the Burrell Miller book
they think it is a book of falsehoods
and those were interviews at the time
they were but they were background
interest he was not the main liver he
was a like a contributing editor to a
series that David Susskind was trying to
put on television the documentary about
President Truman so these were not
there's a guy named Ben gratis that did
some wonderful interviews with Truman
that are much I found much more useful
at a guy named a team named Hillman and
noise also interviewed Truman for his
book mr. citizen wonderful tapes now he
does talk with candor in detail about
his relationship with President
Eisenhower on those tapes and I found
those just immensely useful
can anybody listen to these times yes
they're there at the Truman library they
have transcripts what I prefer to work
with for the most part although in the
case have been gratis I and Merrill
Miller I listen to the tapes I read many
transcripts of
of truman's interviews for mr. citizen
and also for his memoirs where he had
these long legal lengths and it's just
wonderful transcripts much of it
previously unpublished are you I mean
one last question on this book and I
want to ask you what your next book says
did Harry Truman go to Dwight
Eisenhower's funeral he he did not he
was in frail health himself but he
issued a very gracious statement
recalling their great service together
and final question what's next for you
Eleanor and Harry the correspondence of
hairiest Roman and Eleanor Roosevelt
in the death of her husband made him
president he made her first lady of the
world and when's that gonna come out
it'll be out Scribner in September of
next year
Steve Neil we're out of time here's the
what the book looks like Harry and Ike
the partnership between these two men
thank you very much for joining us
thanks Brian